I [ __ ] quit comedy alright hey what's
up it's bill burr I'm doing another
episode of the all things comedy poker
today I'm playing with Natasha Leggero
this is the funnest part Brookes what
are you gonna do ask me if I smoke this
week Brendon ladies and gentlemen this
is your crap didn't speaking nikto
you're the one that gave me MDMA so what
does that mean I think with each one of
these that I do I dress more and more
like a degenerate okay what are the this
is already the most professional game
we've had what are the blinds and also
what's a blind blinds are like whoever's
to the left of the dealer
you have to before I even deal you put a
dollar and you put two dollars in so at
least there's something in the pot if we
all decide to fold oh yeah yeah that was
already nervous about his plane this is
so much better than playing board games
I hate cards against humanity' that's
the [ __ ] least funny it's so [ __ ]
lame and it's just always unfunny people
sitting around going you know Adolf
Hitler's balls doing worse than that is
the stand-up on Southwest Airlines
I [ __ ] hate everybody that laughs and
encourages no but when I see people
laughing at that I'm like I could get
this person to I think proposed to
somebody on a Southwest right I was with
Lynch Shaw Croft we're going to
Stanhope's and the lady we were drinking
on the plane lady came by and I was like
hey can i I want to propose to my
girlfriend make an announcement on the
thing and she's like well we're about to
land I don't know and then she all
excited like right before they were late
she was like and I went up and I was
like I was surprised a little bit into
my cup so I was a little drunk then I
went up and I grabbed the thing that I
go ladies and gentlemen this is your
craft and speaking
there's a lovely lady on this flight who
I'd like to ask for her hand in marriage
Lynne Charles will you marry me oh my
god I wouldn't really say no so he was
like no it was fourth of July weekend
cuz an old lady when she was leaving she
goes I thought this holiday was about
independence we didn't realize she was
like just making a song joke but then we
didn't realize that when we landed we're
gonna be in the Tucson Airport and all
the people from the flight they just got
off the flight too so people are
congratulating guys like we had to keep
the joke going so we didn't look like
[ __ ] for like you know until
everybody got their bags and told them
that was just a joke so they knew there
was no Santa Claus gonna borrow that I
was into my cup I was in my couple of it
sounds so much better than saying you're
shit-faced a little blind big blind come
on we're still playing poker
people are watching for the stories they
don't give a [ __ ] I need this money I
need that hundred fifty bucks guys you
look like you're working on a concept
I'll see your raise I want to see your
next hour stand-up dude it's gonna be
[ __ ] next level by the way I like your
Big Lebowski gloves yeah sorry Bobby
Lee's not here or earthquake earthquake
at least Bobby owned up to it too
there's only so many aces in the deck
this must be how those decks with five
aces and I'll just watch this go down
yes what the [ __ ] I needed I mean
there's no point here for me you talk
about this gamer no just my narrative I
mean I don't think bill has anything so
you can still stay is that legal to do
that
- coach I mean it depends last card
when everybody needed odd 50 boy and
wonder if Bill has a good hand I do want
to see ya do it all right
this is great I got there for us I got
nothing I [ __ ] was so bummed I had
pocket fours net flipped up you don't
believe I will next my oral strength was
yelling about something that I just
learned and didn't really know much
about not knowing how much the chips
were worth was a big strength of mine so
I didn't have the nervousness of wow I
just went really deep in that pot
overall strengths are that I know the
rules of Poker well you're playing with
people who don't know how to play poker
all strategy goes out the window you
just you just have to stoop to their
level my strengths were laughing I guess
my weaknesses are that I'm pretty good
and I know it I had this kind of thing
where every now and again you know when
the cameras weren't on me I'd pull a
knife out and just look at Brennan and
say do you want it or don't you want it
you know and I'll use this knife for
cutting brie cheese's uh not knowing the
game I'll do a Gouda my weakness is
probably also not knowing the game [ __ ]
I've used it on a couple Swami's you
know do you guys get into magic when you
were little my brother got into it he
[ __ ] wouldn't tell me how he did he
did the whole pour in the milk and in
the newspaper like how did you do that
he never told me mmm like my brother is
like old school he kept his [ __ ]
mouth shut until I [ __ ] had friends
that smoke weed then he ratted me out
tell me how the milk
alright so what do I burn one here what
do I do
no no you just deal we each get two I
don't know if it's magic that I used to
my dad would sometimes he would let me
pull his finger and you would fart that
definitely meant that is the beginning
of show business whether I burn one and
then flip boy oh well we got a so I went
to tosha's first act one time my oldest
brother found my dad's weed and he
smoked it and he goes what he's gonna do
ask me if I smoked it sweetie because
that's a good point
and never mentioned oh my god that's
great yes my turn sold me out for a
smoking weed and I looked him up on
Facebook the other day is untraceable
what does that mean untraceable she's
nowhere okay then I started asking
around higher daddy I still carrying it
man that guy's winning you gotta let it
show the guy I bought weed from got
caught with weed by his mom and told her
that I sold it from you you can't tell
on me I [ __ ] hate it just makes me go
to sleep you're getting the wrong kind
you don't have to work for you hi like
drinkin you got to get it down just weed
it's just so [ __ ] easy then you sit
there flip three so there's kind of weed
now that's just called CBD that doesn't
have THC in it but it doesn't it's no
fun I know but it helps you sleep though
and so the other night I bought some in
Denver and didn't really look at it so I
take the CBD and I woke up at 2:00 in
the morning my whole body was vibrating
I've never been as high in my life and
go check the bottle and it was half CBD
half THC and I took five times the
dosage and then I go downstairs and
immediately my son is sleepwalking
what's it like being high and drunk
around your children I honestly don't
know different we're really yeah ever
really been to high or drunk around the
kid I had a few beers you've never been
higher I would hate it so how hammer did
you get around the kids you get
belligerent [ __ ] balls you got no
teeth it took me a decade to realize
that pot isn't for me I think it's cool
though you gave it a decade coming home
and having a few glasses of whiskey I
don't say how big the glasses were
[ __ ] big go I'm too wired
competitively because I just look at a
bottle I'm like I can finish that in
three nights so I was like smoking a lot
of weight at one point and my wife hated
it and I was seeing a therapist and I
was like hey my wife like wants to talk
about my weed intake so can I bring her
in and this guy was kind
like a fan at this point we had a fan of
yours yeah he might stand up my stand up
and he's like so what makes you mad
about him smoking weed and she's like
well cuz it's illegal you know it's like
he's going to drug dealers and he's like
well what if he got his license would
that make you feel better and she's like
I'm gonna guess and he was like well
what else and she was I feel like he's
hiding it from me
and he was like well what if he got like
a jar and he kept it in that and you
just knew where his weed was and she was
like I guess and then we we high-fived
on the way out thanks so much for being
part of the team I ate a weed candy the
other day and then was reading a book
and then my girlfriend got mad cuz I was
just too high to have a conversation who
reads a book when they're high though I
write down I was like this is the first
time anybody's been yelled at for
reading a book I only she had a problem
with the book burn in turning this is
the lingo down there that now I'm trying
to go this whole month priceless oh
really yeah nothing I quit smoking
vice.com at all that's not gonna watch
the channel oh cigar in online porn what
about actual sex no that's good if
you're if you're into online porn you
want to start having sex with your wife
I don't know I think I'm gonna start
working clean and just start doing new
nurse all right this is biggest pot yet
it's a big pot I love it all right so I
got a jack Vera Jack's Rose Natasha it's
all been a ruse no I like this game cuz
you cannot know what you're doing and
you can just say oh I was just bluffing
most impressive well I guess Natasha I
don't know if she was faking us all out
or Natasha I don't know how to play
poker with Cheryl to watch somebody that
doesn't know a lot has never played
cards and it's just kind of smiling and
just saying yeah sure
what's bluffing I don't know what that
means should I put my cards down natasha
is a liar I would say I'm pretty much
ready to start competing professionally
this is a dirty liar she knew how to
play she played us I was walking too
used to be East when I lived in New York
and the drive-by I've gone by so I had
to walk back for they they had taped me
into the crime scene Oh like that's how
recent it was like you taped me in let
me pop out but I had to walk around like
I'm just going right there and then like
arrogated for to Brooks yeah wait sure
I remember I was in San Jose and
somebody got murdered right in front of
the Improv there and when they took a
picture of the body under the bag they
also had the mark and so they had the
name Eddie Griffin destroyed do you get
that feeling before a show you're like
walking around to get dinner you just
see people laughing and you're like [ __ ]
you can't do that you can't judge you
got you got it you got to bring them to
you if you go on stage with that
attitude it's gonna be even worse I know
that's why I don't do funny bones you
are not the man that I saw the last time
I saw you
you're going you buddy this this is part
of it I went through those years I just
remember one night having this horrible
feeling it's like I don't know how much
longer I can do this and then this sort
of creeping am I gonna be the guy who
doesn't [ __ ] never sell tickets and
then I I went back to the [ __ ] comedy
condo and just [ __ ] laid there like
why cuz I didn't know how to talk myself
out of that with the lies Rodney
Dangerfield me quit and he started back
when he was 16 ed Harris went bald he
kept working I would take all of that
[ __ ] once every like two or three years
I think like it's not like a road show
but like a local YouTube's a local la
show like I'll be like maybe I can do it
stoned
and then one minute and i said i'm like
'no can't do it stuff oh god every three
years i forget how bad it is
i watch doug benson one time in san
francisco we were working outside and he
was so [ __ ] high for his whole set he
was trying to take his jacket off i
couldn't figure out what he was doing
with this arm [ __ ] mitt talking and I
was hanging out you know Molly yeah yeah
she was she all of a sudden bursted out
laughing and I was like what she goes
he's trying to get his jacket off and
then we were sitting there was this show
within the show yeah and the whole time
he had his arm back like this any but
was KITT he was crushing yeah destroying
in the whole time he was it was he just
couldn't get it all [ __ ] shoulder
there yeah what do you got yeah no I
admire your moxie
[Music]
poker is it's a combination of luck and
skill I mean I guess it's more skill if
you know how to [ __ ] people into
thinking that you have good hands when
you don't I was impressed by Natasha's
line skills that she didn't know how to
play
definitely luck I was kind of intuitive
things I was like should I bet
everything even though I don't know what
this combo means and like what these two
cards mean I don't have to call the
combo it's called something what do you
call two cards prepare for me poker is
luck again like I said I can't read and
I don't understand numbers so when I see
those shapes and I see the heart you
know that gives me bravery and I see the
diamond and that makes anything you know
money's involved I know what the little
blind the big blind is I know you burn
one now I still don't know which one is
the river then I see the the club and I
think well what about nature you know
are we considering nature here for me
it's all skill nothing but skill
everyone else's luck and then when I see
the Spade I think I want I did want a
[ __ ] murder Brendan at one point you
know with like a there was a stick with
like a kind of a spearhead on it what
time I flew to like New York and then
had to do this thing and then went to
the so I was tired and went to the big
sick premiere but I was like really
tired but I got drunk and I I thought it
would be a funny bit to go to Ray Romano
who I don't know oh you didn't like the
move
really loudly like in front of it I
don't know you hated the movie man
should I go check on my son or should I
stay in here your son is here he's on
the car he's got a windows up I pad
can't leave the windows down someone
will steal your kid I was trying to get
me to bring my kid to this and he's like
my wife will just watch her and I was
like she cries from 9:00 a.m. to 1:00
p.m.
I'll offered to come over and change
light bulbs because most you won't do it
and then I would call TaskRabbit pay $50
for them to come Changeling good lord
and then al said he'd come over and do
it and then Moshe got like really like I
don't want al changing our lightbulbs
and now he like does it yeah yeah we're
gonna masculine name alone what is that
with those internet [ __ ] names we
just stick two things together that was
never stuck together and it just makes
you feel [ __ ] awful when you hear it
and for more to you Natasha what happens
when I lose all my chips you're often
that well I'm out looks like it's down
are you - my man had one thing this
whole time
me neither but that didn't stop me say
that it's all about your attitude a bit
I want to bet it can I better get you
two of these are one do whatever you
want I love how you're figuring out this
game with the most chips if I do this
I'm not looking for help can I ask him
what he would do let's see this what
would you do if he put stuff in don't do
it I think you're supposed to whisper
that ok I'm gonna fold yeah
but I read on I saw in line if you have
to see what has even worse thing she had
five of a kind that's what does that
call five the same suit we had I don't
know what terminology who would most
likely be a cheater I'd say Nixon he's
kind of able to Bluff in the same way I
am and also I would be a cheater
probably Nick Thune because I know he
cheats on his wife well cheating wise
another thing anything was going on at
the table but some was weird between
Brendan and Nick in their marital
situation in the girlfriend situation as
far as cheating goes when I look around
the table knowing that Brendan has you
know cheated on his girlfriend and and
with me I would did walk in on Brendan
and Nick in the bathroom together which
is weird it's the only one toilet
but they said Nick needed help I don't
know and that's an awkward place to be
you know to be around his girlfriend and
know that I've been with him and it's
like our little secret I guess and kind
of the looks that we share across the
dinner table but were you asking about
cheating in the card game though this
tables not like this to where you guys
are all winning all the [ __ ] chips
down there we're just singing the
beatles amazing you not like the cool
kids
no Ringo makes me feel like I can sing
yeah check out the way the Beatles are
spelled that's how you know they're not
cool
you don't like the Beatles it's called
beat like a drum you know I used to
always think that John what John Lennon
was the coolest and then George Harrison
obviously is the best
I found out Beatles was spelt like that
like a year ago and told people I was
like do you not sleep not like the bug
and like yeah
our whole lives those used to trash him
music I can't stand bug music just go
yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah aah screaming high-pitched
that when I watched set for years and
I'm finally this is the Beatles Mike oh
yes trash in them what's amazing is how
much they change in ten years
I don't welcome in Tilt Lake I think
they should have been open yeah no I
mean the stuff in the end all that [ __ ]
was cool
yeah you do yeah why don't work totally
innovative first other than that they
suck - that's like we listen people talk
about Richard Pryor he did white guys do
this black guys do that it's just too
much time has gone by so many people
ripped them off yeah so people don't
they don't get ten I don't need to be
dictated to no that's five yeah maybe
you do this is ten right you've made
this point do I have to do this if you
want to stay in you have to put in at
least one you see that right no we're
giving her advice she's winning every
[ __ ] hand
uh what are we doing here what would I
check to you I checked
what does check me it means anything it
means I'm in a fault well it doesn't
mean that it doesn't you just want to
see the just a little bit one more green
to you I saw Jimmy Walker one recently
he was this woman was going like good
can you just say dynomite yeah he's like
his life is a living hell I opened for
him and he was like I he was the
headliner he's like I'm just gonna host
he just hosts and every elevator
everywhere you go say dynamite dynamite
dynamite dynamite why don't people get
that to just [ __ ] leave the guy alone
and then the people who understand that
it annoys him still [ __ ] do it like
we're probably doing a disservice to
bring this up yeah yeah yeah that one it
yeah oh yeah I'm on to you she does that
six seven that's what you know
understand that you've left one time and
it worked and then it's like well that
works that's what I'll do it
I think the biggest tells people were
giving out is when they were dealt their
hands and they said God these are the
worst cards I've ever seen that kind of
tipped me off a few times that maybe the
people I was playing against didn't have
good cards
I think Brendon I could tell when he was
bluffing - it didn't seem like he really
bluffed much when he had a bad hand he
folded and when he had a good hand he
you know kept playing the tells that I
could see was when Bill and Natasha
would both lift their cards up and I
could see their cards and I would be
like what are you doing bill
didn't know what he was doing even
though it seemed like he played this
many times and I could also tell when he
was bluffing the only person I was able
to read was I think Natasha after a
while once she bluffed at one time that
she's like oh I'm just gonna go with
all-in every time I noticed in a couple
pots in a row she did that and I was
able to take one pot off of her he was
pretty transparent but then she
immediately adjusted her game which is
something I've noticed about women like
trying to beat them and stuff like that
it's like playing against Belichick you
know you might do it for a couple of
quarters and then they come out in the
next half as I figured me out and then
five more - bill okay if you want to
raise you can Nick but let's keep the
game moving all right oh man goes great
with my pocket kings finally something
on the table here so people kills first
time I'm folding bluffing is not gonna
work if somebody else is gonna have that
goddamn king yeah you got it my dough
all right he doesn't have [ __ ] if you
ate the King you would you try to draw
more money out of them okay it's just me
and Nick
all right everybody thrown down the
hundreds look at there's what all the
face cards are Kings left is exciting
kapow whoa all families there
these are was about winning the game I
don't think I'd be doing this because
I've yet to win I like the social aspect
of it you know get a sandwich listen to
some stories
throw some chips and feel like a man
well I mean nobody was paying attention
to the game I don't you know it was like
their play style was to just shoot the
breeze and not really pay attention to
the game I like it I like the drinking
aspect I like the social aspect and I
like that you kind of don't have to know
what you're doing because if people look
at your cards and it was stupid to keep
playing you can say oh well I was just
bluffing you can't really go wrong 1:30
in the afternoon and I've had beers some
a days shot now thanks well thanks
comedy for allowing me to do nothing
today all right burn one flip three yep
I'm starting to get it man
I've only done this [ __ ] thing like
50 times and then next time you're gonna
forget all of it
Oh always so I always flunk tests are
you a part of a real poker game yeah
unlike Monday nights or something like
yeah but it's more of a women no
[Laughter]
all-white Roman Catholic men oh I'll
call wait that's all your money yeah
I'll call we still owe me like $80 when
you ordered all that room service then
put it on my room damn he
remembered because I said I said did you
try to see your room or my room
I didn't [ __ ] won $100 worth of wings
and you're the one that gave me MDMA so
what does that mean you probably owe him
[Laughter]
I've never heard the word hundo cents so
much okay how old you kid
eight weeks just starting to smile like
this week it's the greatest thing ever
you wait they they know how to hug you
she doesn't know only what my thought is
so interested in everything the only way
talk about cards guys sorry bill folded
yeah we won't do a side bet just this is
how I get it a hug barrage is is if you
sing to it she literally puts her head
on your shoulder
it's a great little little hands grat
it's the greatest thing ever you would
all right yeah somebody said it's like
them doing heroin I said I can't believe
it
have you seen those people like giving
that one heroin and that's their play
style was to just shoot the breeze and
not really pay attention to the game I
was doing Kegel exercises throughout
most of the game today I actually found
this group of people fascinating because
we all seemed to at one time or another
really like getting [ __ ] up and we
also all have kids what Brooks doesn't
they're all talking about having babies
and stuff and I was like do you guys
still do mushrooms in the desert I
didn't really have a lot to add to the
baby topic but if we got into desert
mushrooms I'd have been all over that
conversation and been like it's a
mistake
I feel so fulfilled with one child cuz I
wasn't even gonna do one hold your child
I know I ran into one time with hope
dogs and you went out of your way to
make a comment that was anti child I was
like she's never being a mom I got roped
in my son the other day said what's
trust like I don't know how to answer
that you have to learn how to answer
that if you don't have an answer I'm not
giving one okay you know I don't know
okay look I can still afford a house go
don't let those teachers pressures that
have hurt spiel on you yeah like you
need to know everything you don't need
to know everything you just need to know
enough my taught us a while word was
high and high and I want that really bad
[Laughter]
I'm just their own room and let me go
through it oh you know what you're right
you know what I was and I apologize yeah
that's just kind of breaking your balls
[Laughter]
I don't want a big pot there while your
baby talk please put a hundred-foot
black on it and take three of these okay
Brooks finish strong
she's going on I'm calling that's fine
you have to put it on I want to talk I
can go whenever I do something - Tasha
is always right behind me there we go
a pear King there a king she's like I
don't know what an attention that's why
I didn't want you to do that was dumped
you played it very very cool slow flip I
give up you got to play down and so on
all in I [ __ ] quit do I really get
this money yeah well you get most of it
this is like two TaskRabbit thanks
Natasha I would like to say that that
was fun but I lost again problem with
this country is everybody gets a ribbon
whether they win or lose and I don't
want to be a part of that problem
oh I won just counting my money I would
have liked bigger bills but it's okay
the person who knew least about poker
wound up winning the game I think she
didn't know that she won so I could have
cheated in my favor and told her that
she lost and I don't think anybody would
have batted an eyelash eyelash I don't
remember what happened at the end and
this was like 25 minutes ago today was
some of the highest stakes I've ever
dealt with none of the money that I was
playing with was actual money and I
could have won $150 which would mean
nothing to my mortgage or my child's
life biggest moment of the game for me
when I [ __ ] took foon out with that
straight I'd call a hand of the game I
just like looking for reasons to like
smugly drink hand of the game what did I
learn about everybody today I learned a
lot about myself and I I I kind of
walked away thinking I guess I have
things to work on in my personal life
you got a lot of closets to clean and
that has nothing to do with the fact
that I have a six bedroom house with
closets that are just super clustered
this loss is gonna it's gonna eat me
alive I'm gonna take it out of my wife
and kid tonight you get drunk and
belligerent but uh you know I'm gonna
come back stronger we talked to Bobby
Lee an earthquake learn some of the
tricks of the trade and I think I'm
gonna win the next one I think like
internally closet wise I need to come
out of a few of them and just look
around you know but I think the biggest
thing I learned about myself is that I'm
gay
[Music]